unser fragen lotto mit zwei arten von
losen harmlose und furchtlose bei den
furchtlosen müssen so furchtlos sein
weil das gemeine fragen an sie sind und
die grünen fragen sind ganz harmlose
fragen sie können ziehen so viel sie
wollen sie können gezielt sind sie
können wegschauen wie soll ich jetzt ein
ziel oder ein zimmer 110 einzig sollten
dann 110 vorlesen beantworten nächstes
ziel also ich muss doch für den ganzen
berg durch oder wie also völlig egal es
ist immer ein sie können auch immer
sagen eltern können die frage
ja die medizin sollte immer besser
werden wir irgendwann 150 jahre alt
290 vers 10 lautet ein gutes einleben
werde 70 jahr auch 80 wenn es ein gutes
jahr das ist was dran die ewige
verlängerung des lebens wird nicht
möglich sein es gibt
einen biologischen zelltod ob das
nachher bei 150 jahren ist ob das bei
110 220 jahren ist weiß niemand im
moment sind wir noch in der phase dass
die durchschnittliche lebenserwartung
der menschen steigt wir werden in den
nächsten 20 jahren alle etwa vier jahre
durchschnittliche lebenserwartung zu
gewinnen das bedeutet mit jedem monat
den wir leben steigt unsere gesamt
lebenserwartung um eine woche das ist
eigentlich eine schöne aussicht weil ich
sehr viele menschen kennen die heute mit
anstand und format und toll älter werden
das scheint jetzt die schwierige war ja
das ist ein furchtlos
davor können sie nicht fürchten ärzte
gelten als unfehlbare götter in weiß ist
genau das gegenteil der fall und sie
machen fehler am laufenden band beides
ist nicht richtig also erste sind keine
unfehlbaren götter in weiß ärzte lernen
glaube ich heute sehr viel früher sich
mit fehlern auseinanderzusetzen aber
wissen die
ärzte kämpfen sehr mit der tatsache dass
ein fehler den sie machen bei einem
anderen menschen etwas schreckliches
auslöst und genau das führt manchmal
dazu dass ärzte dann die fähigkeit
verlieren zu geben sie hätten was
fehlerhaftes gemacht und das ist für
einen arzt eine ganz große qual jeder
von uns hat schon fehler gemacht und das
gehört eine gewisse größe dazu jemand
aber auch lernen kann zum patienten zu
gehen und zu sagen wir mal dass das und
jenes ist passiert das müssen wir jetzt
entweder durch einen weiteren eingriff
oder durch eine meldung an die
versicherung oder durch irgendetwas
anderes lösen damit mindestens der
materielle schaden und auch der
medizinische schaden begrenzt wird so
weit dass nur irgend geht ist das ein
unlösbares problem weil man ja auch
wahrscheinlich mit einem wandern auch
noch im gefängnis steht das gefängnis
ist nicht das zentral wenn jemand etwas
getan hat war mit dem bein im gefängnis
steht dann ist das ja kein fehler dann
ist das ja eine richtige schuld darum
geht es nicht es geht im kern um die
frage wie man mit dem haftungsprobleme
und mit dem versagen als arzt klar kommt
das ist ein riesenproblem für ärzte und
dann auch für patienten das kann man nur
durch aufklärung durch offenheit
transparenz lösen aber da hat sich in
der medizin und habe mich viel verändert
in letzter zeit die halbgott in weiß
zeiten sind vorbei ein punkt darf man
dabei nicht hintan stellen kern des
problems ist die asymmetrie des
verhältnisses ein arzt und patient der
arzt ist den patienten und das meine ich
jetzt überhaupt nicht ausland durch sein
studium und durch seine erfahrung oft in
den dingen um die es geht so weit voraus
dass der patient ist niemals
hundertprozentig verstehen kann ich
halte deswegen auch das konzept vom
mündigen patienten für zu weit gehend es
ist manchmal schlicht nicht möglich bei
allen dingen diese mündigkeit
herzustellen erleben wir plastisch an
der schweine epdm debatte ich muss doch
die wissenschaftlichen argumente der
probleme der wirkverstärker
darlehen ich darf sie nicht verschweigen
und mache ich mich ja auch schuldig aber
ich weiß dass ich damit jeden verwirre
und verängstige der nicht mehr an die
unfehlbarkeit der medizin glaubt
muss ich wieder genau
warum opfern sich ärzte so für ihre
patienten auf
hintergrund unglaublich lange schichten
war ja auch ein grund für den streik des
marburger bundes also erstens glaube ich
dass unser beruf unbeschreiblich viel
bestätigung liefert und spaß macht ich
habe ja auch während meiner ganzen
britischen tätigkeit immer nebenher auch
noch gearbeitet zwei tage die woche
ungefähr haben das mache ich immer noch
hier weil das ist einfach ein toller
beruf
ich sehe das gar nicht als aufopferung
oft sondern ich sehe das als die
natürliche konsequenz
mangelnder ressourcen mangelnder mittel
und einfach der tatsache dass die arbeit
da ist gibt es übrigens auch in ganz
vielen anderen bereichen und berufen da
wird nicht so viel von baumwolle und um
gemacht
trotzdem wäre es schön wenn man
diese opfer bereitschaft der ärzte nicht
schon als im ethischen teil der bilanz
gleich mit in die kameras bilanzen und
in die krankenkassen bilanzen einstellen
könnte sondern wenn man die ärzte für
ihre aufopferungsvolle tätigkeit dann
wenigstens anständig bezahlen würde
jetzt das denn inzwischen der fall oder
sind sie noch nicht zufrieden nein
ergeben sie sind überhaupt nicht
zufrieden aber es ist besser geworden
täuscht der eindruck oder sind nicht
sehr viele ärzte überheblich
ach ich weiß nicht ob der anzahl die
anzahl der ärzte die überheblich sind
höher ist als die anzahl den anderen
berufsgruppen ich kenne auch in anderen
berufsgruppen viele überhebliche
menschen mit verlaub so wie es auch bei
journalisten
aber
die asymmetrie der informationen
zwischen arzt und patient führt dazu
dass das mehr wissen
des arztes oft von patienten dazu
überheblichkeit aufgefasst wird ich
glaube im kern sind die nicht
überheblich als alle anderen menschen
auf der welt auch aber es kommt manchmal
so rüber
sind auch persönliche fragen und ich
hoffe sie klingen ist eine persönlichere
rum weil sie meinen jetzt heisst weiter
warum sind sie nicht der präsident der
bundesärztekammer
ja weil
der war ich das letzte mal nicht
kandidiert habe und der wahl körper ist
anders entschieden hat jede zeit hat
ihre präsidenten und es ist ja noch
nicht die letzte messe in diesem thema
gesund aber das ist schon eins ihrer
ziele sie haben so viel spaß an dieser
politischen arbeiter sie sagen ich will
da auf dem posten wo ich was richtig
bewegen kann die das gefährt ist eine
debatte ist zu sagen ich will ein
politisches amt bekommen dann wird man
zu einem grund gezogene kind
abgestempelt und dann dann wird das
nichts sondern tatsache ist dass es eine
situation geben muss und davon bin ich
überzeugt dass auch die ärzte sagen der
ganz gut vertreten und der wird den job
gut machen das heißt sie verweigern sich
nicht das klingt dann auch immer so
wissen sie ist es ja auch nicht so dass
man immer nur gerufen sondern waren
organisiert ja auch manchmal die eu
fällt das gehört zur politischen alltag
dazu ich halte das für völlig normal
ich habe jetzt nur zufällig grünen
griffen nicht sagen
woher sind sie so redegewandt
also ich hatte immer spaß spaß an der
rede mein vater war anwalt vielleicht
liegt es daran sie sind ja auch quasi
zweisprachig aufgewachsen ich bin
deutscher englischer sprache
aufgewachsen meine frau ist schwede
nicht sprechen zu hause aber manchmal
schwierig zu besetzen meiner kinder
natürlich dass dann auch die sprechen
das fehlerfreie und die feder von eltern
sind immer für peinlich aber ich kann
einfach relativ gut französisch aber
dass das hat der liebe gott mir nie
wiege gelegt ist das immer bei ärzten
soll ich stelle es oft fest dass ärzte
noch ein zusatz talent und zwar einen
markt und musikalisch zum beispiel sehr
oft violinisten sind dabei ich weiß dass
ich immer ob es talente sind ich stelle
auch fest dass viele ärzte andere dinge
neben mir auch noch ganz gut machen
außerdem dieses primär gelernt haben
das liegt vielleicht daran dass die
medizin
keine ganz konkrete klassische
naturwissenschaft ist meine
erfahrungswissen schafft zum einen und
das macht man ganz viele erfahrungen am
rande die einen dann dazu bringen auch
noch was anderes zu tun und das andere
ist glaube ich dass man durchaus auch in
unserem beruf hin und wieder die
komplette abdeckung braucht weil man
kann nicht alles was man den beruf
erlebt mit nach hause nehmen ich habe ja
auch eine gewisse zeit strahlentherapie
gemacht wenn ihr damals nicht das segeln
gab es etwa wo ich abends meinen frust
in den winter hätte schreien können dann
wäre das schwierig gewesen und ich
glaube deswegen gibt es viele ärzte mit
einer zweiten begabung also deutschlands
größte schriftsteller sind teilweise
ärzte gewesen viele musiker haben
medizin studiert und das ist schon toll
der beruf lässt eben einem auch für
sowas freiheiten nur noch mal zur
erklärung strahlen medizin man hat
einfach auch viel mit todesfällen zu tun
wir das nicht immer erfolgreicher in den
in den frühen achtzigerjahren
strahlentherapie betrieben bevor ich
dann diagnostische radiologie wurde und
die strahlentherapie ist eine
damals war damals im bereich der
anfänger der krebsmedizin da habe ich
man vielleicht auch von menschen gesehen
ja
privatpatienten gelten als optimal
medizinisch versorgt fallen da die
kassenpatienten nicht immer öfter unter
den tisch
da müsste ich ihnen eine radio eriwan
antwort darauf geben ja und nein also
privatmaschinen patienten werden besser
versorgt heutzutage was die termin
häufigkeit die geschwindigkeit was den
komfort angeht nach wie vor haben wir
aber einen gesundheitswesen in dem auch
der normale patient mit allem was
wirklich wichtig ist was notfall ist was
schnell gemacht werden muss genauso gut
wie der privatpatient allerdings bei dem
was warten kann mutet man den menschen
heute das warten zu weil die
krankenversicherung schlicht keine
ausreichenden preise bezahlt und da muss
man jetzt nicht dass für die
privatpatienten schlechter machen wie
die alte regierung vorhatte aber man
muss es für die kassenpatienten besser
machen das ist der einzige weg wie das
geht und ich glaube wenn ich den
koalitionsvertrag weise dass die neue
regierung den ansatz zumindest hat und
ich wünsche ihr glück dass sie das
geschafft ist
das gesundheitssystem nicht jetzt schon
unbezahlbar nein das gesundheitssystem
ist nicht unbezahlbar aber es gehört zu
den aufgaben der politik zusammen mit
als gewehrs träger von gesellschaft zu
definieren wie viel wir in einer
gesellschaft bereit sind für
gesundheitssysteme auszugeben und das
kann sein dass man wie in einem land wie
russland entscheidet mehr als drei
prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts
stellen wir nicht zur verfügung
dann bekommt man auch nur eine leistung
von 3 prozent oder wie in deutschland wo
wir sagen etwa zehn prozent sieht dass
wir bereit sind dafür auszugeben
dann kann man damit eine ganz andere
leistung darstellen wir haben ja zwar
ein holprig organisiertes
gesundheitssystem aber wir haben hier
einen fantastisch funktionierendes
gesundheitswesen weil bei uns ist ja die
versorgung der leute nach wie vor mit
die beste auf der welt aber diese zehn
eineinhalb prozent sind die gesetzt oder
wenn du nicht jedes jahr wieder ein
bisschen ach jetzt wir haben und es ist
wieder toll geworden der eindruck
täuscht die 10,5 prozent sind natürlich
überhaupt nicht gesetzt die hängen zwei
grössten an der entwicklung des
bruttoinlandsproduktes auf der einen
seite und an der kostenentwicklung im
gesundheitssystem an der anderen seite
und was das für dramatische veränderung
machen dann kann man in der
wiedervereinigung am besten sehen wir
hatten in alt westdeutschland früher
immer nur zwischen achteinhalb und neun
prozent am bruttoinlandsprodukt für die
gesundheitsfürsorge und mit der
wiedervereinigung haben wir 16
anderthalb millionen neue bürger in das
system aufgenommen mit 100%
leistungsanspruch haben aber nur zwei
oder drei prozent am
bruttoinlandsprodukt zu bekommen und so
sind wir ohne dass sich an der
gesundheitsversorgung aber das verändert
hatte über nacht von 85 prozent auf 10 5
prozent drauf gesprungen weil schlicht
und einfach das ist der nachteil
prozentualer berechnung und sieht die
rechnung basis die grundlage sich
verändert hatte das ist so und das zeigt
eigentlich wie gefährlich solche
berechnungen sind aber muss man nicht
irgendwann sagen da ist die grenze und -
waren es gibt ja kalkulationen die sagen
gegen 10 20 jahren sind wir bei einem
anteil am lohn von 43 prozent für die
gesundheit das ist ja niemand bezahlt
war da ist ja das problem werde schon
jetzt zwei dinge miteinander verwechseln
ich rede vom anteil am
bruttoinlandprodukt sie reden vom anteil
am lohnt das hat ja miteinander zu tun
ja eben zudem weniger das ist genau das
aber das ist genau das problem zunehmend
weniger weil zunehmend weniger menschen
in abhängiger beschäftigung als
alleinverdiener für die aufbringung der
beiträge zur krankenversicherung zur
verfügung stehen wir werden in zukunft
sehr viel mehr einkünfte aus
kapitaleinkünften aus selbstständige
unternehmertum
einkünfte auch zb aus renten oder aus
renditen auf
einnahmen die man während der arbeit
erzielt hatte die man dann im alter
frühstücken will das werden wir mit
berücksichtigen müssen weil nur noch der
prozentsatz vom lohn wird nicht reichen
weil unsere kinder da dürfen wir uns gar
nichts vormachen werden nicht bereit
seien 40 prozent ihres einkommens für
die krankenversicherung der erwachsenen
oder der älteren der der rentner
aufzubringen und deswegen ist das reiner
selbstschutz wenn wir uns heute mit
premier modellen auseinandersetzen wenn
wir heute versuchen eine
finanzierungsbasis zu schaffen die es
auch unseren kindern noch ermöglicht in
deutschland gesundheitssystem zu haben
und krankenversicherungen zu haben das
hat ja bisher noch keiner diese
gesundheitsreform gemacht dieses problem
letztlich löst also der liga so seins
fonds
kommen mehr kompromiss als lösung der
gesundheitsfonds ist ein absoluter uns
in der gesundheitsfonds nichts weiter
als ein paar tagen des problems gewesen
und der gesundheitsfonds ist ja nur in
der versuch zu einer einheitskasse zu
kommen indem man wettbewerb endgültig
tötet und das ist der wirklich eine
koalitions missgeburt gewesen die man
hier zahlen kann nein wir müssen
langfristig die frage beantworten kann
man solidarität innerhalb einer
gesellschaft besser organisieren über
die beiträge zu einer
krankenversicherung die dann von
krankenkassen manager verwaltet werden
oder kann man sie besser organisieren
über steuern indem man sagt die
politiker müssen bei der priorisierung
der ausgaben des staates eben auch
berücksichtigen dass es menschen gibt
die sich die gesundheitsversorgung nicht
leisten können und muss denen zuschüsse
aus staatlichen mitteln sprecher steuern
geben hätte ein riesen vorteil wenn man
dann nämlich auch noch in einer
steuerreform endlich steuergerechtigkeit
einführte und die die ganz viel geld
verdienen auch noch mehr bezahlen müssen
und die die wenig verdienen eben nicht
alles immer bezahlen müssen dann hätte
man hier wirklich solidarität und
ausreichend geschaffen ich glaube die
regierung ist auf einem guten weg ob sie
das schafft das ist ja keine aufgabe die
man in einer legislaturperiode hinkriegt
sondern das ist eine aufgabe die man vor
allem in der abwicklung der koalition
allen sozialversicherung die 30 jahre
dauert das wird ein spannender prozess
sein aber da haben wir ja alle für uns
auch noch heftig einzumischen gute
bewerber gespannt jetzt dürfen sie
auswählen ob ich zuerst die
lust oder die trotzdem france sieger
lust haben wir nicht lust aber wir
möchten gern den frust am ende
warum gilt das deutsche
gesundheitssystem als eines der besten
der welt
wir haben durch unser gesundheitssystem
ist geschafft den menschen eine fast
barrierefreien zugang zu allen
sinnvollen und vernünftigen leistungen
zu schaffen es gibt bei uns keine
selektion ehrung nach alter geschlecht
rasse
reichtum oder ähnliches sondern alle
menschen bekommen in deutschland das was
sie
nötig haben manche ja sogar er fast ein
bisschen zu viel
das ist das eine das zweite ist wir
haben in deutschland eine tolle
wissenschaft eine tolle forschung wir
haben hervorragend ausgebaute
krankenhäuser deswegen haben wir in
meinen augen nicht eines der besten
gesundheitssysteme sondern das beste das
un system auf der welt übrigens die
größten kritiker unseres
gesundheitssystems haben alle eine reise
rückhol versicherung damit wenn sie im
ausland krank werden die ganz schnell
nach deutschland fliegen können sich
hier behandeln zu lassen
trotz zuzahlung für zähne brille und so
weiter und so fort ja über zähne im es
ganz viele die meist und dann andersrum
die meisten gesundheitssysteme der welt
kennen überhaupt gar keine gut ausgleich
der zahnbehandlung das und bei zähne hat
ja anders als zum beispiel eine
krankheit kein statistisches risiko
jeder von uns rüstung zahnarzt dafür
müssen sie in der sparkasse finden wo
sie ihr geld sparen prospektiv um es
dann zu haben wenn sie ihre zähne
reparieren lassen müssen und sie können
selber ganz viel tun regelmäßige
zahnhygiene das erleben wir heute an
unseren kindern die alle löcher mehr
haben dafür brauchen sie eine sparkassen
und keine versicherung aber wir brauchen
eine versicherung für die risiken die
sie nicht einkalkulieren können und die
deswegen von der gesamt verdeckt werden
müssen jetzt kommen wir zur spannenden
final frage warum sie nicht
gesundheitsminister geworden wovon mich
nie einer gefragt hat werden sie es
gerne geworden wäre dass du einen job
oder ist das so viel also jetzt und so
nah wie gruppen unter druck der stress
ist es nicht die frage ob man sich das
zutraut ist es auch nicht aber man muss
doch einfach mal eines sehen ist man
klug beraten
angesichts des zustandes unseres
parlamentes heute und der frage dass wir
dort überwuchert sind von beamten
juristen und lehrern ist man klug
beraten einen ausgewiesenen
lobbyisten zum minister zu machen ich
könnte doch bei allem respekt
nicht unter aufgabe meiner
persönlichkeit plötzlich vergessen
machen lassen dass ich schon des
marburger bundes wahr dass die spitze
der bundesärztekammer bin und dass ich
mich für ärzte einsätze und deswegen ein
gesundheitsminister soll mehrheiten in
parlamenten organisieren können dazu
wäre ich nicht prädestiniert weil ich
würde sofort den widerstand aller
anderen lobbygruppen und ich würde den
widerstand der sich nur als politiker
verstehen politiker gegen mich haben und
deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich sogar gut
dass ich nicht gesundheitsminister wenn
also ein job wird wenn sie ungeeignet
wäre ein job für den ich nicht
ungeeignet wäre aber nicht ungeeignet
gemacht habe durch bisherige tätigkeiten
kinder